peut-être une solution donc à la pénurie
de sang vous savez qu'on a de plus en
plus de mal dans les centres de
transfusion à trouver des donneurs
volontaires une nouvelle technique vient
d'être mise au point aux états unis
plutôt que de transfuser des globules
rouges on injectera plus que de
l'hémoglobine qui amène l'oxygène dans
les tissus plus de problème de groupe
sanguin plus de risques d'infection
le détail avec jean-daniel physique
grâce aux progrès de la transfusion
on sait depuis longtemps apporté du sang
une victime d'accident de la route qui
souffre d'une hémorragie importante
on peut aussi compenser les pertes
sanguines d'un opéré mais pour cela il
faut avoir assez de donneurs de sang
veiller à réduire au strict minimum le
risque de transmission d'un virus et
surtout avoir une compatibilité stricte
entre les groupes sanguins du donneur et
du receveur
alors pour essayer de simplifier les
choses les chercheurs de la société
américaine baxter eu une idée se passer
des globules rouges les globules rouges
contiennent une substance que l'on
appelle l'hémoglobine
c'était mon globine est une sorte de
porte manteau sur laquelle est accroché
l'oxygène cet oxygène va circuler dans
le sens et être distribués à nos
différents tissus
le principe est simple on extrait
l'hémoglobine du globule rouge et on se
simplifient la vie puisqu'il n'y a plus
de risque infectieux il n'y a plus de
cellules et surtout plus de problème de
groupe sanguin
cette technique devrait donc rendre de
grands services au médecin de samu qui
pourront transfusé au bord des routes
sans s'occuper de savoir si les groupes
sanguins sont compatibles mais il trouva
aussi d'autres indications notamment
dans le traitement des artères bouchées
dans le cas d'angine de poitrine ou bien
encore d'artérite car en même temps que
l'on introduira des ballons pour guy
l'atc artères on pourra passer cette
hémoglobine là où les globules rouges ne
passait pas c'était mon globine qui
amènera un véritable ballon d'oxygène à
ses artères bouchées